bob for the padres is adrian morihon
and adron takes them out tonight 2021
season debut he has faced the giants
before
tonight marks his fourth career
appearance his third start against the
giants
last season yeah he's got swing guy he
started nine games he appeared uh
also in four other games not starting 19
and a third
overall you know the guy's got some uh
good stuff he just needs to hone that
strike zone so slater's gonna hit first
you see his numbers
one for 12. the one hit a home run
and this is hit on the ground and off
the glove of croninworth
and that should be a base hit and that's
how this game gets started
not trying to do too much stays inside
it's so good
he did edward was scalded
tapped out in front of home plate it's
going to be carratini who's going to
throw out solano
and slater moves down to second so why
is it being a swinging bunt but a
productive out
the infield here in san diego is pretty
quick
flores lifts this one into straightaway
center field
and it'll be tommy fam who makes the
catch
two outs for evan longoria owen won the
count
slater leads from second here's the
pitch and a little bouncer to hit softer
to short tatis has it the throw to first
just in time to get him by a step and
that retires the side
so lead off single by slater but he ends
up being stranded at second
on the hill tonight four the giants will
be the veteran right-hander
anthony de slefani diesel funny in his
seventh year at the big league level
six feet tall 200 pounder
and he shoots this one the other way and
it's right at slater
and slater will make the catch on one
pitch and that'll bring up machado
now the stretch here it comes there's a
fastball driven
deep uh right field toward right center
back and on to the warning track but
he's backpedaling all the way
austin slater makes the catch that got
him excited here at petco park
but it did not come that close to the
wall
so two down and here is eric hosmer
national league player of the week
rough appeared in two of their three
games in seattle and was over four
a season ago in his first year as a
giant he appeared in 40 games
and hit 276. now the pitch change up
there's a drive
deep into center field fam is back he
turns he looks up
and goodbye darren ruff got another
change
up and this one he planted over the
center field wall
to give the giants a one-nothing lead
well and he hits a home run in a
two-strike count
and he took some really and when
marijuana had a challenge he didn't want
to walk him
ruff jumped all over it nice and bad
here's the pitch down to buster posey
he swings and lines a fastball in the
right field of base head
well that was we mentioned part of the
giants game plan
be aggressive on that fastball so three
and two to carratini first base now open
with the pitcher on deck
giertini lines it into center field
coming around from second is profile
here comes the throw
it's up the line this game is tied one
to one well the elective pitch to victor
caratini with the pitcher
up next and he drives in the game tying
run looks like a breaking ball it's a
slider
and it comes right back over the heart
of the plate
and victor comes through big time even
the diving crawford can't get to it
and the friars tie it up so here's more
honu bats left-handed he has one major
league at bat and he struck out
swings in the first pitch grounds into
third longoria will go the short way to
force out carratini at second
and that's all for the padres here in
inning number two but they tie this
thing up
one out in the third fernando tatis
junior fly to right
swing and a miss and tatis hurts himself
on the swing
fernando goes down after strike three
and appears to be clutching his arm had
the shoulder problem during spring
training
i kind of wonder if that's the situation
here as he's holding that arm as he
walks off
so on that follow through and that's
where he oh yeah cradles it
immediately to the belt buckle fernando
headed to the clubhouse
is there a worse site for padres fans
than that right there how quiet did this
crowd get
hassan kim has taken over for fernando
tatis jr at shortstop after tatis had to
leave the game
evan longoria about to lead it off as we
head to the fourth inning here's the
pitch and longoria swings and drives one
to right field
going back on this ball myers at the
wall it is gone
evan longoria has done it again another
opposite field home run his third home
run of the year already it's two to one
giants
and once again he goes the opposite way
with power
and eva longoria pounced on a fastball
morahon i don't know what the idea was
behind that pitch he'd gotten longoria
to chase down
and he left one out over the plate away
and longoria just did what he did
in seattle beautiful opposite field
swing
hitting it with power to the right side
man second and third instead of first
and second with two down it's owen two
now pitching and a fastball struck him
out swinging
95 miles an hour dee schlafani
reached back here in the end of the
fifth dug deep and struck out both
hosmer
and tommy pham to get the giants through
the fifth with
the lead still two to one that's the
score giants ahead
one and two on profile one out nobody on
and this pitch pissed it out towards
right center field on the run slater he
will not get there
now it gets by duvaughn as well and
rolls towards the warning track
profars hit second on his way to third
throw from solano not in time
oh that was misplayed by the giants in
the outfield it was one thing not to
make the catch that's fine
but then the center fielder dubon and
the right fielder slater kind of stood
there
and it bounced between them rolled away
and profar ends up
on third base tying run now 90 feet from
home
time run 90 feet away victor caratini
carratini reaches out sends it to center
caught in center field by dubon but
tagging his profile and this game is
time
nice catch by devon and a sack fly off
the bat of carrottini
it's here's the strimski hitting for
berger
now he has swings and he hits a drive
into deep center field going back his
fam all the way back at the wall he
leaps
and jario's pelota
mike yaskrimsky with a pinch hit home
run over the center field wall
his first home run this year and that
gives the giants a three to two lead
andres have left ten men on base tonight
they're one for six with runners in
scoring position
have two on two down for tommy fam two
on two out the three one pitch
swing and there's a drive into center
field medium deep but back to the edge
of the track
goes dubon steps onto the track and
makes the catch
the ball game is over